During a big transformation and changes to their global setup,...
...Ernst and Young made special efforts at internal communication.
It was paramount to connect with people and inform them about these innovations.
During their business trips, team leaders were asked to spend time arranging face-to-face get-togethers...
...with different departments at various locations, talking and listening to staff.
The simple "meet and greet" sessions enabled free flowing conversations...
...that personalized the proposed changes.
Because a record was kept of these meetings, information could then be spread widely among departments,...
...which kept people informed, especially those who could not attend.
Because of the large staff turnout at these meet and greet sessions,...
...this form of communication has now become a popular way for leaders to interact with employees.
Web and podcasts are now also being employed to unite staff further.
It was a morale boost for individuals to hear their questions and concerns answered.